i'd like to share seven
surprising
underlying causes to autoimmune diseases
now the reason i'm talking about this
topic is because it's literally an
epidemic out there there's so many
people that are developing autoimmune
diseases all over the planet and i'm
going to talk about what i think is
going on now the quantity of people
getting autoimmune diseases is ranked
number three after cancer and heart
attacks
yet there's other reports that show that
it there's more people with autoimmune
disease than both of those combined in
fact the top-selling drug on the planet
is an anti-inflammatory that deals with
autoimmune diseases so the question is
what the heck is going on what is
causing
our own immune system to turn on us
and attack our own tissues that's weird
isn't it
so to answer that question i think it's
not a good question i think there's a
better question because if you look up
the underlying cause of autoimmune
diseases it's going to say unknown
it could be genetics it could be
environmental we just don't know we need
to do more research but a better
question to ask would be this what
causes an immunodeficiency
or an immunosuppressive
state in your body or your immune system
is suppressed to the degree that
it's non-functional so this barrier this
wall this defense of your immune system
somehow
is lowered to the point where things can
then happen
and your body can incorrectly tag the
wrong thing
and end up with a bit of a friendly fire
it's kind of like if let's say for
example you have to go to court right
and there's a jury there and maybe
there's confusion and they incorrectly
label you as guilty and now they tag you
as an enemy and then now you have to
suffer all the consequences that go
along with that well with an autoimmune
disease the same thing happens
your own tissue is incorrectly labeled
and now your immune system attacks that
and then you have all this collateral
damage that occurs from the inflammation
that's caused by your own immune system
now another interesting question that
also relates to this would be what makes
your microbes that are in a dormant
state like for example epstein-barr
virus it goes into this dormant latent
stage and then one day it comes out and
it ends up attacking us right so the
question is why what's the difference
between before and now there's even a
condition where your immune system
becomes suppressed
and friendly bacteria morph into
unfriendly bacteria or microbes that are
neutral they're kind of
they're not hurting you or helping you
turn on you that's called an
opportunistic infection where your
immune system is taking advantage of a
situation and then the problem medically
with these conditions is that they're
just managed okay they just manage them
with more medication like prednisone and
then the side effects just continue
they don't really know what to do with
this condition now what you might know
about autoimmune diseases is that
they're triggered by certain chemicals
in the environment okay maybe toxins
leaky gut okay definitely if you have
any type of digestive issues or even
thyroid issues i mean certain things
like bad eating can create holes in your
gut
that then cause proteins to leak through
your gut so then your immune system
incorrectly tags those as foreign
proteins and then we have this whole
immune reactions now certain drugs can
cause autoimmune diseases cortical
steroids are a well-known thing that can
trigger autoimmune diseases and of
course
chemotherapy but let's talk about the
underlying causes that you might not be
aware of okay and this is actually quite
interesting
number one excessively clean
environments okay
as a child is exposed to this planet
they're born with part of their mother's
immune system it's called the innate
immune system and then they develop the
acquired immune system as they acquire
it by being exposed to the environment
and interacting with microbes and then
developing their immunity that's why
it's important not to have someone be in
such a sterile environment all the time
because there's no training for the
immune system so it's normal for kids to
get sick so if a child gets sick and you
quickly stop the fever or give them
medication to suppress it they never
really develop a good immune system and
there's something called the hygiene
hypothesis and they found that kids that
are in a sterile environment they're not
around microbes too much they have a
higher risk of getting autoimmune
diseases down the road
especially versus kids that are raised
on the farm or kids that are around pets
or kids that are not in a sterile
environment which is interesting
number two
okay
i'm not going to even mention this i'm
going to just show you the book okay the
textbook which is 120 you can buy it on
amazon and you can very clearly see
this connection which i'm not i can't
really talk about but there's a huge
connection between this topic and
autoimmune diseases and you can research
this data yourself but this book which i
have as a textbook goes through some
seriously credible information
on something that's probably not going
to be in the news all right number three
infant formulas wow
instead of breastfeeding if a child is
put on infant formulas
their tendency to get autoimmune or the
risk for getting autoimmune goes up okay
and i'll put that research down below
which is actually another
interesting and surprising thing that
people
don't connect the dots with number four
a problem with the vdr what is vdr
vitamin d receptor
there's some good research which i will
put down below that talks about
improving autoimmune diseases with
correcting the vitamin d receptor
so vitamin d
is not a vitamin
it is
a very uh powerful
steroid okay in the body
that is intimately connected with your
immune system there's over 19 000 genes
that they have identified with vitamin d
so every part of your immune system
needs vitamin d in fact vitamin d
regulates your immune system okay and if
you don't have enough
you're very susceptible to getting an
autoimmune disease in fact i would
venture to say that every single person
who has an autoimmune disease is low in
vitamin d but you can have a problem
genetically with the vitamin d receptor
the term is called a polymorphism
and if you have that you're more at risk
of developing autoimmune diseases as
well
and these darn microbes both bacteria
and viruses
have a strategy of blocking the vitamin
d receptor because apparently they have
the intelligence to know that if they
shut that down the entire immune system
is shut down
so you'll see in the next slide what
we're going to recommend to improve this
vitamin d receptor which actually even
goes beyond just taking vitamin d very
interesting number five
this is a big one losses
which is a major stress event okay
when i was in practice i would always
ask a person who has an autoimmune
disease when did it start what happened
just before i'm gonna tell you it was a
hundred percent of the people
that told me this occurred after a major
loss in their life a death a divorce
a loss of a job
things that are related to stress in
general can trigger
an autoimmune disease because when you
increase cortisol
which suppresses the immune system okay
it lowers your white blood cells it
leaves you vulnerable and susceptible to
things happening where your immune
system is misidentifying certain things
and this is why one of the major
treatments
for autoimmune diseases
is a synthetic version of that cortisol
called prednisone
but the problem is it comes with a lot
of side effects
number six antibiotics interesting that
relates to number seven loss of the
microbiome right so when you don't have
all the right
microbes in your gut
either whether you killed them or some
other reason you're more susceptible why
because 80 of your immune system is your
microbiome okay it's these microbes
apparently have a very
interesting arrangement with our own
cells in that we help them and they help
us and
part of the agreement is that they
protect us against foreign pathogens and
so we appreciate that
all right let's get to the next
slide right here what do we do about it
you need to
beef up no pun intended your vitamin d
at least 20 000 i use vitamin d also
take the vitamin k2 with it i have a lot
of videos on that i'll put the link down
below but vitamin d and i'm talking
about vitamin d3 not vitamin d2 okay
it has to be vitamin d3
can help to
put back in that regulation of your
immune system okay very important
but does that fix the receptor not
necessarily
there are other things that can help
that vitamin d receptor and one is
bile salts okay
which virtually has no side effects and
the one i'm going to recommend is tut
cup okay so take both of these and as
far as the amount of tuck i would
probably recommend taking
one or two in the morning on an empty
stomach and then one or two
in the afternoon an empty stomach at
least four
three weeks and then maybe go down to
one in the morning one in the afternoon
after that as a maintenance dose until
you're in
good shape
probiotics are key
now here's the thing if you have an
autoimmune disease
especially that's related to your gut
okay
and you may have sibo this might not be
an option right away because you might
feel
more bloating with these probiotics
you're introducing more microbes and you
have microbes maybe in the wrong place
in your small intestine or you have
some imbalance of microbes that can
create an immune reaction so i always
recommend going very slow with these
probiotics i mean like maybe a a fourth
of a teaspoon just if you're taking a
liquid right before bed or maybe a
fourth of a capsule right just a small
amount because they can turn on an
immune reaction
and this relates to number four reducing
fiber
if the gut is involved okay
so i'm going to put this one right here
if the gut is involved so if the guts
involve we have an imbalance in this
microbiome and you start putting fiber
in there and you put probiotics
and maybe you have a small intestinal
bacterial overgrowth that can just stir
up a lot of bloating so if you don't
have gut problems then definitely take a
probiotic okay
and maybe not worry about the fiber and
of course the fiber i'm talking about
the fiber from salads things like that
i would definitely not recommend ever
getting your fiber from grains or
legumes or beans and this is why if
someone has an autoimmune problem
that's related to the gut they will
definitely do better on a carnivore
keto plan than something with a lot of
fiber
all right number five a keto plant which
means you're doing low carb and you're
doing
quality ingredients right you don't want
to put all that sugar in the system or
carbs you want to get in a keto plan
because
ketones in general are anti-inflammatory
okay we're trying to reduce inflammation
and number six this is the a really
important factor fasting this is how
you're going to correct your immune
system there's quite a bit of data on
doing fasting and improving autoimmune
diseases especially if you do regular
intermittent fasting between the longer
fasting whether you do three days or two
days but if i were you
at least every two weeks i would do a 48
hour fast and it would do regular
fasting if you could do one meal a day
that would be
the best thing you could do but at least
two meals a day but fasting is going to
strengthen your immune system fasting is
going to lower your
inflammation in your body and of course
number seven do whatever you can to
reduce the stress we want to do a stress
detox if there are people in your
environment that are stressing you out
avoid them right now you need to be in a
healthy environment and the next most
important video for you to watch would
be on this topic on fasting so i put it
up right here check it out
you